liebe leute in diesem community video
wird die frage aller fragen endlich
geklärt nicht was ist der sinn des
lebens die antwort kennt 42 nein
wie kommt man in den geheimen leoparden
modus das und viel mehr erklärt jetzt
pro jan müller michaelis im community
video was ist dir persönlich das
wichtigste an ein videospiel
beziehungsweise wodurch zeichnet sich
für dich ein gutes videospiel aus möchte
happy flummi 123 wissen ja hallo happy
flummi ich denke videospiele sind sehr
unterschiedlich und können sehr
unterschiedlich sein
das ist ja ein sehr großer bereich und
ich denke jedes genre und sub genre und
jede hat neue genre mix muss andere
kriterien erfüllen um spaß zu machen
gut ist es fertig da braucht zum
beispiel gute rätsel und eine gute story
aber dasselbe gilt eben nicht für ein
autorennspiel und ich persönlich spiele
halt auch sehr unterschiedliche genres
also ich spiele zum beispiel sehr gerne
2d jump'n'run spiele spiele super mario
unglaublich gerne aber auch eben diese
neuen art die 2d jump'n'run spiele und
da kommt es mir eigentlich hauptsächlich
auf den spaß an also dass die physik
stück sozusagen wie springt der
charakter und eben dass das ganze aufbau
dass die lernkurve gut ist beim
adventure ist es natürlich erst mal die
story aber auch dann die puzzle und ich
glaube grundsätzlich lässt sich nur
sagen es muss ein unterhalten irgendwie
es muss spaß machen und unterhalten muss
ja nicht unbedingt heißen dass man halt
die ganze zeit über lacht oder die ganze
zeit über viel am drücken ist sondern ja
es muss halt einfach ein gesamtprodukt
sein dass mich halt
ja vielleicht pukki und christoph ich
hätte mal eine frage und die lautet
warum wolltest du damals adventure
machen oder anders gefragt was gefällt
dir an diesem genre
das war dann meine frage eigentlich auch
schon
ich hoffe er dass die und ich sagte ja
das ist tatsächlich sehr berechtigt frei
ist ich glaube tatsächlich der grund
warum ich hier spiele machen wollte war
dass ich sie vermisst habe dass jemand
anderes mehr so gemacht hat wie ich
gerne spielen wollte natürlich es kam
halt anfangen 2000 also in 2000 2010 ist
ein für morgen nahmen die nuller in den
nullerjahren da gab es halt das ein oder
andere adventure aber insgesamt galt ja
das genre als tod und das fand ich
unglaublich schade und ich wollte es
wiederbeleben ich glaube das war mein
haupt mein hauptanliegen wird es niemand
anderes macht den meister leben selbst
soethe 3500 fragt wie kommt man in den
geheimen leoparden modus das natürlich
ein sehr gut gehütetes geheimnis
wir haben ja leider also wir haben zu
jedem spiel gibt es von uns gibt es auch
den geheimen leopard modus normalerweise
drucken wir deshalb in den kurzer
anleitungen wie man diesen geheimen
leopard modus gerät in die in das
handbuch ab leider ist uns da halt ein
kleiner tippfehler passiert bei den
letzten malen und ja ich kann jetzt
leider gerade das nicht korrigieren die
zeit reicht auch nicht aus aber ihr
müsst einfach mal in der dritten zeile
gucken da steht irgendwo sind da drei
ist wenn ihr die durch 1 ao und alu
ersetzt ich glaube dann sollte es passen
damals kann auch sein dass ich mich irre
decathlon fragt wie fängt man am besten
mit dem spiele programmieren an und
welche programmiersprache hast du für
dein erstes game benutzt haben ja ich
habe tatsächlich nur für erbrecht aus
selbst programmiert und noch nicht da
war ich halt der hauptmieter ich bin ja
hauptsächlich spieleautor tatsächlich
ist ende april aus damals als
studentenprojekt auf java entstanden das
eigentlich eine sprache die man gar
nicht so für für ja gar nicht so mit dem
für videospiele einsetzende lernen
sprache aus die sehr gute sprache und
einzusteigen in das programmieren und
man kann halt auch schon viele sachen
macht man ja am beispiel von apple
bricht aus sieht ja sonst
schau dich einfach ich würde sagen ein
abgeschlossenes studium ist auf jeden
fall sehr hilfreich versucht euch da
hinzuarbeiten dass er versucht hat
irgendwie informatikstudium zu holen
aber es gibt auch sehr viele gamedesign
studiengänge mittlerweile drei fragen
hatte
erstens die caps eigentlich orgel bester
zweiter willst du nach telefonierer
eigentlich noch einen dritten teil der
innereien machen und wenn das zeigte
schon eine idee dafür und dritten wo
sich für eigentlich der leg
entertainment in den kommenden jahren
größer an dich und christian er hat die
erste frage war wie ich auf drogen
becher kam ich habs gerade eben nicht
nicht wirklich gehört wie kommt man auf
sachen also ich glaube ich wollte ich
kann ich kann die frage beantworten weil
ich einfach gar nicht weiß also manche
ideen kommen halt einem werden einem
kuli runterfällt während man auto fährt
und sich den kopf an handschuhfach stößt
ich glaube das war so eine idee ich
wollte hauptsächlich glaube ich dass der
name lustig klingt also der name trockel
becher ist einfach entstanden weil ich
den spieler halt irgendwie also ein wort
präsentieren wollte wo das gehirn
irgendwie denkt so da muss doch
irgendwie ein sinn dahinter stecken und
dann lässt es sich auch gar nicht
auflösen ich glaube es war im endeffekt
und alles schlag auf teure synapsen also
sowas gedacht die zweite frage war die
zweite frage war gibt es jetzt ja ich
möchte natürlich sehr gerne in
saint-nazaire sum wie produktmanager von
uns das gedacht hat zurückkehren
ja ich ja
wurde einfach unglaublich gerne wieder
texte für hp und apple schreiben dass
ich auch für mich dort wieder sehen wenn
ich texte für alte charaktere von mir
schreiben kann das habe ich jetzt bei
dem vorjahr 2 gemerkt also bei chaos auf
dem podium wie viel spaß es macht halt
fortsetzung zu schreiben weil es halt
wie ein altes wieder sehen dass wir so
eine art
junien und deswegen ich würde sehr gerne
machen aber natürlich brauchen wir dafür
auch den richtigen partner und die
richtige zeit und er weiß dass es steht
noch in den sternen aber er will es auf
jeden fall da und die den übrigens auch
und die dritte frage wie sieht es in
zukunft aus mit einer firma ja ich denke
dass der blick auf jeden fall immer
weiter geschichten erzählen wird
interaktive geschichten und wir machen
ja wir entwickeln uns immer sehr sehr
kleinen schritten weiter sage ich mal
oder gameplay bleibt recht klassisch
aber wir feiern sehr viel an dem
gameplay mit dem einzelnen den kleinen
feinheiten und ich denke dass da noch im
wie in der gesamten branche wir haben
vorhin drüber gesprochen hat noch ganz
viel neuland zu erkunden ist sowohl im
storytelling als auch im gameplay
ich glaube wir werden bei kommenden
spielen durchaus auch mal mutiger werden
vielleicht werden wir sogar das genre
komplett verlassen
wir werden aber immer interaktive
geschichten erzählen ja auch leute war
bei kriegsende und hat im community
video eure fragen beantwortet und unter
anderem erklärt warum er lieber kein
vorbild sein möchte sondern entertainer
und wer war noch da haseloff sind dennis
schneider der ist deutscher meister bei
starcraft 2 und er wurde gefragt was war
dein erstes game ist ja vielleicht ganz
interessant wäre auch mal deutscher
meister werden will der sollte das
unbedingt wissen
bis dann